joining me now is colorado congresswoman
lauren bobert member of the house
freedom caucus congresswoman
your response to
my point that everyone who has influence
in the republican party who's more of a
populist proponent of the america first
agenda
they should expect that they're being
surveilled or in some way targeted by
the biden administration do you agree
with that
laura unfortunately i do agree with that
because i have seen exactly what this
department of injustice is capable
recently and how they feel about
conservative americans how they feel
about moms and dads attending school
board meetings and it goes so much more
beyond that look laura i'm magga i'm
ultra vaga and i'm proud of it but that
simply means i believe in securing the
southern border reducing government
spending
uh securing american energy and
protecting
our
our peace through strength and
protecting women and our our children
and protecting american greatness we
don't need an army of 87 000 irs agents
never before has a president shown such
hatred for his fellow americans my job
above all else is to secure your freedom
is to secure your rights to keep you
free i want what's best for the american
people joe biden he wants what's best
for the democrat party as well as the
chinese communist party joe biden stood
in front of independence hall and gave
one of the most disgusting and decisive
speeches in american history a speech
that was laughed at and mocked by nearly
everyone except for the lefties the
american people they don't need a
lecture they need an apology from joe
biden and laura
joe biden it's very very clear is
suffering from an illness in addition to
cognitive failure tds
trump derangement syndrome and
i'm pretty sure it's at a level four at
this point joe can't talk about his
accomplishments because he does not have
anything so instead he'll just get up
there and say orange man bad and hope
that the media will cover for him joe
biden is not some sad sweet old man he
is an angry radical that is hurting
america he is attacking his political
opponents and he is going after them
again and again he should resign and if
he refuses i hope that my house
colleagues join me
in my articles of impeachment to get him
out of there well congressman jamie
raskin i know you guys are good buddies
defended uh biden's anti-maga rhetoric
this weekend saying this
two of the hallmarks of a fascist
political party are one they don't
accept the results of uh elections that
don't go their way and two they embrace
political violence and i think that's
why
president biden was right to sound the
alarm this week
congresswoman your response to that not
accepting the results of an election and
stoking
uh political violence or or supporting
political violence is that what magazine
laura i was
i was proud to join 146 of my colleagues
and objecting to the electoral college
results of the 2020 election this is not
something that was unprecedented
democrats have objected to the last five
republican presidents and no one had
such outrage for their objections to
that certification there was clear
constitutional issues with the state
legislatures that were subverted in
election laws and i think that that was
our fundamental role as representatives
to say hey let's take a pause and let's
look at the constitutionality of the
election that just took place but of
course the democrats they want to slap a
name on it and call it something that it
wasn't and run with their narrative and
the media helps them that's why i'm
grateful for folks like you laura who
help us
actually get the truth out to the
american people
well i always get lost in all their
invective you know it's semi-fascist and
it's fascist then he kind of walks it
back then it's just the elected
officials it's not the people that
speech was a flop i was sad that i was
on vacation because i wish i was
covering in real time but it was a
complete flop and they know what that's
why they had to try to walk it back
congresswoman thank you for joining us
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else